how's it going bros my name is very pop
we're playing a puzzle game great idea
fun - oh my god this [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] sorry I have a lot of anger
built up inside this game is so hard
I'm not even [ __ ] I like I can see I'll
already [ __ ] up
we'll figure this out together just be
patient are you a patient woman man
great double genders I have no problem
with the either oh great oh my god are
you [ __ ] kidding me okay five
fabulous fabulous ass holes in my dick
hole that I just referred to my okay
great I know I don't care this game is
gonna destroy me there we go suck a dick
what do I do now Oh again please oh my
god sucks so many penises [ __ ] my that's
a checkpoint just let me finish it baby
let me finish y'all let a girl who this
looks tricky
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey uh Stan uh who did the smartest
[ __ ] alive girl go I can't tell
if I'm a [ __ ] I mean if some stupid or
if I'm a genius
this is the saddest [ __ ] thing this
is the saddest playthrough of this game
ever like a box of candies just pop in
the bunch of Mexican kids never seen
Canada before that's why take a shooting
star that's very poetic isn't it you
know a save hit we got [ __ ] say we
have one more stage breast whoo no more
toast a shot oh I'm proud of me I'm
proud of everyone I'm proud of myself
I want to thank Jesus and cheapest just
watch other thing is that right why
didn't these guys split up okay all
right we're we're one of the last sheeps
let's answer to the last question did
you just pee somewhere I swear to God
[Music]
it seems you've survived thank you so
much experience you'll need luck as well
somebody got out of here before I'm
gonna do even better than it's more than
one person depending on me now okay what
is it you got a food two more
[ __ ] please I can't handle it two more
finished climbing this thing tomorrow
and move up tomorrow
tomorrow tomorrow what does that moon
this is the boss now or later I don't um
what did other people answer whoa
more ed Garin oh my god my I've said
I've thought more that this playthrough
than I ever thought in my life like ever
didn't uni or anything this is
ridiculous
you both should play this game and tell
me if you don't struggle like holy [ __ ]
oh man I can't wait yes
suck a dick suck a dick suck a big fat
dick [ __ ] that's what I'm talking about
that's how I get all the ladies we're at
the cathedral baby baby why can't we
just be together almost eros let's talk
to our last sheep just watch
back she will be mine are you the only
one here were the others attitude Jesus
final final well I already nothing is
gonna scare me off now the question are
you able to physically punish someone if
you believed it was the right thing to
do
I could do that yeah by century I hear
there are more holy stares with red
carpet at the top of the cathedral get
there but don't let go of what's
important to you if you can tomorrow
tomorrow hurry up and take me up there
[Music]
trial made for me Catherine so do I care
about Catherine or not I don't insane
we'll see I guess and what are you bro
stink leave a comment girl
ah this has been amazing so far I can't
wait to see how this story ends that's
what I'm really like why I want to just
finish the puzzles because I know I'll
play more of the puzzles alright alright
alright
look at that we're almost at the table
this must be a but yeah it's a boss
battle now seven loading spiral corridor
final floor thank you fantastic just
what I wanted a life did you pee again
I heard you pee it's my dad fantastic
someone who know you well he got me in
here it must be him
shadow of Vinson oh it's me I got myself
in here what is going on right now Reiji
nickname he Oh
[ __ ] are you doing Nate
yeah obviously right there come on let
me do it oh my god I knew it was him
breast Fox Steve
what a twist of fate it looks like I'm
cursed you figured something out it's
revenge Oh
shits about to get
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
not stay
stay
[Music]
- [ __ ] Great Escape
you're survived I can't I can't believe
I spent I spent all day I spent easy hey
and four bronze for [ __ ] bronze Bros
I can't oh dude I am NOT very smart am i
well I did it it did and I'm proud of
myself
don't let anyone say you're not good
enough for anything here we go
this is what I waited for for so long do
we ever change our underwear it's kind
of gross it's been eight days you know
what I can respect that I can respect a
man who do remember now
if he's still in it I had a dream where
I felt dead struggle I was being chased
by something crazy and we've had these
crazy droves every night so how come we
can't remember them clearly he still
doesn't remember poor Steve
[Music]
hey you alright man
whoa that dead guy on the news just now
I know that he lived in my neighbor the
police came this morning
oh so that sounds like a bad way to
start the morning was cheating on his
wife with a younger woman
the entire neighborhood knew because he
bragged about it to everyone hey what is
it
we met last night in my dream huh
met who I remember now it was he in
steam he died in my train him guy in the
news that's crazy talk man What did he
say
that's right it's it's starting to come
back to me now he said it was a curse
because he betrayed someone
hey cut that out you're trying to tell
me he was killed in his dreams or
something you are [ __ ] crazy
well maybe not think about it the rumor
maybe it's true
the dreams who have been having every
night you honestly just say that how
does this tie in with betrayal I'm the
one that got betrayed sorry enough
[ __ ]
we just can't think straight because
we're too damn tired you wake up all
bleary-eyed in the world's full of
rumors then we can't sleep because all
this crazy [ __ ] stuck in our heads
you're probably right
exactly that actually makes sense you're
making me so hungry so wise just
thinking it's all stupid yeah man what
about you you dumped the girl you're
cheating why actually I was gonna go
talk to her after this it'll be a
horrible date but I've made up my mind
I'm ending it I see and this is all done
I'm gonna propose to her to the one I
know I love of course I haven't bought a
ring yet the ring can come any time good
luck yeah
this goes I'm so into this I don't even
want to talk over am just like same
phase you're making jumping on that oh
hey there's something I wanted to tell
you check this out
yesterday I finally became a man way
back up take a wild guess it should be
too hard
Oh gave away my vCard I'm so [ __ ] so
weird about it you know I can't really
explain it it's probably just because it
was my first time maybe you know just my
imagination but so what happened to
Johnny here come here by yourself yeah
he's not coming today
kinda weird everyone's tired all the
time
Vincent's infected us dinner so you see
I mean there's nothing wrong with you so
then there's someone else isn't there
I've been meaning to tell you all this
time
but I couldn't I had a lot of things on
my mind and then you came along yes I
was trying to escape reality do you like
her more than me
look I'm sorry she's someone I really
need to hold dear oh dear
wait so does that mean you're already
dating her I'm sorry
just throw the drink in his face what
you might not mind but I do why you want
to know why
[Music]
she's pregnant she's crying I guess she
really meant all those things she said
damn it Vincent you betrayed her
feelings you took advantage of her damn
right you did no no no no no no no no no
I'm fall asleep it was a mistake all
right
oh ouch you can't say that I'm not good
yeah no I don't have any money so no
matter how you spin it
I'm no good for you you're still young
so you probably just went with the flow
so I know I'm being a real jerk
but we need to end this I'll do anything
else you ask of me anything else
what else is there I'm going to die
please don't say stuff like that I just
Catherine wait what the [ __ ] hey
Catherine II was I mean II
do I look like I'm okay take it back I
can't do that
I'm sorry I'm really sorry I'll do
anything
[Music]
[Music]
no weapons dude what's up with that
that was Vincent's voice right man is
okay but that just means I want to be
even less involved
[Music]
how will it end how will it end
if he need tall bear booty beetle Vince
hey chief you all right there buddy
we're heading home now what's the story
you staying here how's his face
oh hi Erica infant why don't you go home
you look terrible I deserve it I lied to
her I heard her - you're just gonna have
to swear never to do this again it's not
the right thing to do but just pretend
this was a bad dream you don't have to
try and cheer me up
I need to apologize to Catherine someday
this isn't something I can keep quiet
about look just don't stress yourself
just go home early today and get some
sleep okay
yeah I'll go after a couple of drinks
tonight I think I might actually be able
to get some sleep
Toby uh-huh yeah coming
and then leave him like that
[Music]
[Music]
are we gonna meet up with Catherine now
oh man
[Music]
anime
[Music]
I'm finally back wait for me I can't
believe we still our final is trivia
liquor is usually consumed for the
purposes of getting drunk but some
cocktails exist for the opposite reason
one such cocktail in real very oyster
the recipe is Worcestershire sauce
tomato juice vinegar pepper ham
raw egg it's meant to be swallowed in a
single gulp so that the yolk remains
unbroken yeah that was not very nice
Chartier
sorry to keep you waiting it may be your
fault
but what's tough is I'll treat you to a
drink we'd like to talk to the ladies
tell you a wonderful story over 70
thousand people died of unknown causes
every year in this country only 5% of
them become clear after an autopsy what
there are probably more men who are
dying in that way than we are being told
I think if the game trying to tell me
that this story is true oh my god
please for the love of God we should
just get going I'm scared
[Music]
I can love the atmosphere this game it's
so awesome
ah but it's almost almost finished I
don't know I am I just gasps hey Dave
isn't room we did it
no nightmares what oh I haven't felt
like this in a while just add me I'm
saved
I sure [ __ ] hope so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Catherine waits for me Catherine
Catherine coops
give it up already
[Music]
yeah I was asleep
it's nothing but you weren't answering
your phone We Need to Talk okay we do
okay come on in
[Music]
what are you doing here
oh god this can't be happening so you
need to have a chat with Vincent right
come in make yourself at home how about
a cup of coffee
hmm we are going inside and you're going
to tell me exactly what's going on here
so if I'm not mistaken it would appear
you have another woman in your life
yes no no she's just if you're going to
make excuses can you at least look me in
the eye I would never cheat on you Edgar
let me get this straight then you got
into this even though you knew I was
pregnant
with your Josh it I need to figure a way
out of this no no that isn't it I
thought you were acting a little weird
recently but this it it's not what you
think
so much is going wrong you've got to
believe in your okay here we go
and two sugars for you just the way you
like it Vincent
hey you so what do you think maybe now
would be a good time to break it to her
Vince she's extra baggage in your life
rap I never said that what are you
saying I know I don't want to hear any
more of your [ __ ]
sit honey you're not really gonna try
and play dumb now are you after all
you've done to my body
night after night Oh Pig if you work
hard enough to get something you'll give
it don't you think that's true
well he worked me hard and now he's got
me simple as that
plus I'm sure you have no idea this even
but this one's a wild man in the sack I
don't think you can satisfy him anymore
Wow what are you damn sick in the head
or something nice and honey Vincent here
only needs one thing in this world all
right and it's sitting right next to him
now take a hint
and get out of here why the hell should
I you're the one who should be leaving
[ __ ] careful you keep making faces like
that and you'll start getting wrinkles
I've just gotta calm them both down
[Music]
so can you ever forgive me
damn wait a second I can explain
[Music]
man in a shake
oh man poor Catherine uh-oh what is she
reaching for where's your easel what is
she doing what is she waiting for this
what the [ __ ] is going on hey take it
easy will ya
look just listen to me I've already
called it off with her she just snuck in
here okay please you gotta believe me
[Music]
what Catherine Jesus [ __ ] who is this
really happening
[Music]
calm down calm down Jesus just calm down
everything is gonna be fine no listen
you go home right now leave the rest to
me just do it
come on what
what's it's her we have to run Catherine
follow me what's this [ __ ] scary loud
breath
no are you [ __ ] me
oh my god
welcome to the Cathedral this final
stage requires you and your lover to
reach the final goal fantastic
call your companion to guide her and
escape this chump okay we're gonna have
to do it tomorrow because I have to go
I'm sorry arrest we would like or maybe
I'll upload it to try and figure out how
to get it up tonight but I'll roast
thank you for watching as always stay
awesome Road